la jeune télé mûri vite les caméras de
direct permettre bientôt à suivre de
nobles événement ici à londres le
couronnement de la reine elizabeth
c'est le premier reportage en eurovision
un organisme créé par jean marcy
directeur de la fpf et par la bbc
britannique
cette pompe ce style somptueux mais
jamais pompiers parviennent en direct
qu'en france le conte de fées devient
miracle et le commentaire de jax albert
donne à tout jamais au bon républicain
français le goût du spectacle
monarchique
moyennant quoi elizabeth et le prince
philip se présente chez vous dans votre
salon comme si vous faisiez partie de la
famille et les gardiens de la tour de
londres et les robes d'hermine et les
bilans des caleçons chez vous magix
faisait bien qu familier la télévision
mesdames et messieurs en soins ou très
proyas mans ce faisant elle acquiert une
magie un pouvoir que le pouvoir va vite
apprendre à utiliser car vous êtes déjà
en france à ce moment là quelques
millions de téléspectateurs et quand le
général de gaulle est rappelé aux appels
sa pensée politique vous est proposée en
direct